digamos que tengo un bloque con una masa
m ok entonces digamos este es un bloque
que tiene una masa digamos tiene una
masa m y esto que ves aquí es un plano
inclinado o puedes pensarlo como una
rampa o como una cuña digamos y ahora lo
que queremos hacer es pensar que le
puede pasar a este bloque ok y
empezaremos por pensar sobre las
distintas fuerzas que interactúan sobre
él ok entonces vamos a suponer que todo
esto que estamos dibujando se encuentra
cerca de la superficie de la tierra y
digamos que de hecho es este digamos que
esta base se encuentra sobre la
superficie de la tierra y que no es muy
alto muy bien entonces aquí podríamos
pensar muy bien en la fuerza de gravedad
muy bien y recordemos que la fuerza de
gravedad es justamente la fuerza que
atrae
a esta masa hacia el centro de la tierra
y que de hecho debe ser perpendicular a
la superficie de la tierra y por
supuesto también la el centro de la
tierra está siendo atraída hacia el
centro de esta masa verdad entonces esta
fuerza vamos a llamarlo la fuerza de
gravedad y de hecho sabemos cómo
calcularlo verdad digamos esto es masa
por la el campo gravitatorio de la
tierra digamos que estamos en la tierra
muy bien entonces ahí tenemos nuestra
nuestra fuerza de gravedad y uno podría
pensar también en una fuerza normal
verdad pero la fuerza normal recordemos
que actúa de forma perpendicular a la
superficie muy bien entonces el detalle
aquí es que va a ser muy distinto a como
cuando estaba o cuando siempre dibujamos
esto sobre la superficie de la tierra
entonces lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es tratar de descomponer esta
fuerza de gravedad en digamos en una
fuerza
perpendicular a esta superficie de este
plano y otra que sea paralelo a este
mismo plano muy bien entonces de esta
forma vamos a poder ver guay y analizar
cuál es la fuerza neta que resulta de
este ejemplo de este dibujo muy bien
entonces vamos a intentarlo entonces
digamos que aquí este vector lo podemos
descomponer como un vector que es
perpendicular a la superficie muy bien
aquí debemos poner un ángulo de 90
grados entonces ahí tienen una primera
parte y digamos que vamos a llamarle a
este digamos una fuerza que corresponde
a la gravedad pero en su componente
perpendicular yo sé que está con esta
nota notación es no convencional pero al
menos nos ayudará a entender cuál es
cuál muy bien entonces justamente esta
es la que es perpendicular a nuestra
superficie y por otro lado tenemos
héctor lo podemos descomponer también en
un texto en un vector que es paralelo a
la superficie muy bien entonces la suma
de estos dos vectores y ya podrías
revisar o repasar el concepto de suma de
vectores en nuestras listas de vídeos y
de esta forma estos dos vectores al ser
sumados nos dan este vector que es fg
que es por supuesto al apunta hacia el
centro de la tierra muy bien entonces ya
que tenemos esto lo que prosigue es
utilizar geometría y trigonometría para
saber bien cuánto digamos cuál es la
magnitud de cada uno de estos dos
vectores porque ya sabemos la dirección
y el sentido que toman lo único que
necesitamos saber es cuánto mide cada
uno muy bien entonces de hecho este
quizás déjenme hacerlo un poquito más
grande para que se vea más claro de qué
estamos hablando
más o menos más o menos ahí está ok
entonces a este vamos a llamarle efe
qué es la fuerza de gravedad pero su
componente paralela a nuestra superficie
y entonces aquí es cuando vamos a
utilizar geometría porque si ves este
este plano inclinado no está inclinado
inclinado perdón este de forma
arbitraria sino que está inclinado por
un ángulo theta que ya está fijo un
ángulo de ataque y está fijo y estoy
suponiendo que este ángulo de aquí es de
90 grados es decir este plano es un
triángulo recto muy bien entonces si
nosotros tenemos que este ángulo es teta
y este ángulo de aquí es de 90 grados
entonces uno fácilmente puede saber cuál
es este ángulo de aquí y eso es porque
la suma de los ángulos internos de un
triángulo siempre debe sumar 180 grados
entonces si tenemos 90 grados y theta
vamos a tener que resolver lo siguiente
tengo que este ángulo que no conozco
vamos a llamarle x si ahora le sumo
si ahora le sumó 90 o bueno de hecho
puede ser más más inmediato verdad si la
suma de estos 13 180 y aquí tengo 90
entonces este de aquí
estos dos deben sumar 90 verdad pero si
éste mide theta éste debe ser 90 menos
theta de tal suerte que si ahora tú
sumas 90 menos te está más theta nos da
90 y luego si sumamos 90 nos da
justamente 180 ahora lo siguiente
recordar lo siguiente de la
trigonometría o más bien de la geometría
más básica podemos recordar está esta
imagen en donde tenemos dos rectas
digamos esta recta y esta otra y vamos a
suponer que estas dos son paralelas
estas dos son paralelas si uno toma una
recta que sea transversal a estas dos
rectas paralelas entonces sabemos de la
geometría básica que estos dos ángulos
alternos internos
en la misma magnitud digamos son son
congruentes miden lo mismo muy bien
entonces esto lo podemos repasar de la
geometría básica y que de hecho lo
demostramos en las listas de geometría
que estos ángulos internos alternos son
iguales entonces para para aplicarla en
nuestro ejemplo uno puede tomarse esta
línea en particular vamos a tratar de
retrasar la esta línea en particular ok
esta de aquí
ok esta de aquí junto con alguna otra
que sea paralela pero esta línea de aquí
es perpendicular a la superficie del
plano y sabemos que también esta línea
de aquí que corresponde al vector
digamos de la fuerza gravitacional está
de aquí también muy bien entonces con
estas dos rectas ahora necesitamos una
recta transversal y quizás tú ya la
encontraste justamente es esta recta que
da la superficie del plano muy bien
entonces tenemos esta recta transversal
a estas dos paralelas podemos utilizar
justamente este argumento que tenemos
aquí para encontrar cómo son los ángulos
y si te das cuenta este ángulo será
igual simple quizás solo es cosa de que
lo asocien con este verdad aquí está
esta corresponde con esta esta línea
corresponde con esta otra línea entonces
la transversal corresponde a la
superficie del plano y por lo tanto este
ángulo corresponde a este y este otro
corresponde a éste entonces
ángulo de aquí mide 90 - que está muy
bien ese ángulo que hemos marcado muy
bien entonces ahora recordemos que esta
fuerza la fuerza perpendicular era
justamente perpendicular a la superficie
de la del plano verdad entonces si éste
mide 90 grados este de adentro también
mide 90 grados y finalmente uno puede
adivinar cuál es este ángulo que no
sobra verdad porque este ángulo si lo
llamamos x ahora sí vamos a hacerlo
tenemos equis y tenemos un ángulo de 90
menos teta verdad y tenemos otro ángulo
que es de 90 eso debe sumar 180 grados
muy bien 180 grados entonces aquí
tenemos 90 y 90 son 180 de ambos lados
entonces estos dos 90 se cancelan con
180 y nos queda que x menos teta es
igual a 0 o lo que quiere decir que x es
igual a la teta pero teta
era nuestro ángulo de inclinación
entonces esto de aquí este ángulo de
aquí es justamente el ángulo teta ahora
podemos utilizar la trigonometría para
hallar cuánto mide cada una de las
componentes
el tanto perpendicular a la superficie
como paralela a la superficie de la
fuerza de gravedad muy bien entonces
vamos a utilizar geometría en este
momento aunque hay trigonometría de
hecho entonces si yo quiero por ejemplo
ver cuál es el cociente siguiente
digamos que quiero calcular la magnitud
de la fuerza gravitatoria o más bien de
la componente perpendicular de la fuerza
gravitatoria por ejemplo si lo dividimos
si lo dividimos entre digamos si nos
tomamos este ángulo theta aquí tenemos
el cateto adyacente y éste corresponde a
una hipotenusa verdad eso simplemente de
trasladar este vector
abajo verdad este de aquí se mide
exactamente lo mismo y entonces podemos
pensar en este triángulo rectángulo
entonces tengo yo el cateto adyacente a
este ángulo si yo lo divido entre entre
lo que mide la hipotenusa pero la
hipotenusa es m de verdad que es el
campo gravitatorio gravitatorio perdón
entonces estamos dividiendo entre m g
que es la magnitud de la fuerza de
gravedad verdad entonces lo que estamos
haciendo aquí es calcular el cociente o
la proporción que hay entre la magnitud
de la componente perpendicular de la
fuerza gravitacional entre la la norma o
la magnitud de todo el campo
o de toda la fuerza gravitacional muy
bien entonces esto a quién es y ahora
tienes que recordar las funciones
trigonométricas y lo más sencillo es
recordarlo con el soca toda verdad
entonces tenemos cateto adyacente entre
hipotenusa corresponde al coseno de
nuestro ángulo muy bien entonces aquí ya
podemos simplemente despejar cuánto vale
la magnitud de la componente
perpendicular de la fuerza gravitacional
si multiplicamos de ambos lados por la
magnitud de m&g entonces tendremos que
la fútbol a la norma o la magnitud de la
componente perpendicular de nuestro
campo gravitacional es igual a la norma
o la magnitud de mg por el coseno de
teta
por el coseno dt está muy bien entonces
ahí tenemos la primera fórmula que nos
dice cuánto mide esta fuerza grave o
esta componente de la fuerza
gravitacional para el otro eje el eje
para el otro ejemplo es es similar
verdad aquí tenemos bueno éste voy este
vector de arriba que es que mide
exactamente lo mismo que el de abajo
entonces podríamos también calcular este
cociente verdad la magnitud de la
componente paralela a la superficie de
la fuerza de gravedad dividido entre la
magnitud de la fuerza de gravedad esto
ahora corresponde al cateto cateto
opuesto verdad si este es el ángulo este
es el cateto opuesto dividido entre la
hipotenusa entonces corresponde a el
seno del ángulo esto es igual al seno
del ángulo teta y si hacemos lo mismo de
multiplicar por la magnitud de
tendremos la norma con la magnitud es lo
mismo de la de la componente paralela a
la superficie de la fuerza de gravedad
es igual a la magnitud de m&g por el
seno del ángulo por el seno del ángulo
entonces espero que realmente haya
comprendido de dónde vienen estas
fórmulas para que dentro de 30 años si
quieres volver a estudiar física puedas
nuevamente deducir las ahora estas cosas
son útiles porque digamos si este plano
pues no no le evita ni se va ni ni
digamos se sume en este plano quiere
decir que debe haber alguna fuerza que
puede ser justamente la fuerza normal
que se cancela con esta fuerza o esta
componente perpendicular a la superficie
de tal suerte que lo único que nos queda
es esta fuerza paralela y que va a
acelerar por por la segunda ley de
newton esta fuerza paralela va a ser que
este este objeto esta masa
hacia abajo del plano ok entonces si si
estas dos fórmulas que estoy enmarcando
aquí se te llegan a olvidar simplemente
tienes que digamos hacer uso de la
intuición mira pensemos piensa en ti
intuitivamente lo siguiente si el si
este ángulo theta digamos se hace cero
entonces no tenemos ninguna inclinación
este cuerpo estaría justamente sobre la
superficie de la tierra verdad pero si
el ángulo buenos y si no tenemos el
ángulo entonces justamente tendríamos un
ejemplo como los que hemos trabajado en
vídeos anteriores toda la fuerza sería
perpendicular al plano y por eso es que
si el ángulo es cero
el coseno de cero es uno y entonces toda
la fuerza perpendicular es esencialmente
toda la fuerza de gravedad mientras que
no habría fuerza paralela porque el seno
del ángulo sería cero y así puedes
recordar cuál corresponde al coseno
igual al seno